our next guest is someone that i'm very
personally invested to meet i've never
met her before
but she is a chef author and the owner
and creator of one of the most sought
after restaurants in america it's called
the lost kitchen
but her path to success wasn't always
easy here is the story of aaron french
i went to college when i was 18 but i
became unexpectedly pregnant with my son
i was only 21 at the time
so i came back
pregnant and feeling pretty deflated
and the only thing that i knew how to do
the only thing that i felt comfortable
with was
food and i started a supper club
as the supper club started to get more
popular i
finally got to a point where
i opened a restaurant
but if you want to find some cracks in
your relationship if you open a
restaurant you will find them
my marriage exploded with that
restaurant
i
started to become extremely depressed
i started
drinking more
i started taking prescription drugs
i had a breakdown
i
checked into rehab
my marriage
ended
i lost my restaurant i lost everything
even though i went through some pretty
hard times
those tragedies
brought me the restaurant and the women
who were there we wouldn't be there if i
hadn't tumbled down
if i hadn't gone through hell
[Music]
she's
before
erin joins us now ladies and gentlemen
erin french
thank you thank you so much
now
i mean the lost kitchen is a place uh
that is
reservation only via
postcard
yeah look at them all what gave you the
idea to do a postcard only
lottery system i know it sounds crazy
right you think everyone's supposed to
just move faster and go on open table
and you know we started this restaurant
in the middle of nowhere and had no idea
i mean everyone told me i was crazy like
why would you open a restaurant in a
town with 700 people it's not going to
work and you're a woman in a male
dominated industry it's not going to
work right well
i think after three years we crashed the
phone lines with over 10 000 phone calls
for our reservations in the spring and
it got to a point like we can't do this
anymore we can't listen to these garbled
messages we've overloaded the fire
department had showed up because we set
off alarms and
so we thought what do we do right now we
have to slow this down and for me
because i'm kind of old-fashioned
we thought what about postcards what if
people mailed in for reservation and we
just pulled them out of a hat because we
were never going to be able to feed the
need so many people wanted to come and
we were shocked to find out we thought
people we were just like write your name
and phone number and send it to us and
that's not what they did
we got stories and deep stories and
beautiful stories and you know sometimes
they were limericks or poems or they
were just pieces of people's lives and
for us
being this deeply personal restaurant
where i want to give this deeply
personal meals what better way to get to
know our guests like we're getting to
know them before they arrive already so
that's it's really connected and it's a
journey you travel to get to this
restaurant i've mentioned to people
myself like oh i'm dying to go to the
lost kitchen they're like well good luck
with that
you know i mean you people literally
wait years to get in
so it's a journey i mean kudos to you
for building something that's such a
success
you never imagined
but you built a whole tribe
of women yeah my village yes tell me
about that well
if you think about opening a restaurant
in the middle of nowhere and you know i
was coming out of this just terrible
divorce i had come out of rehab for
issues with prescription drugs and i
wasn't like the best candidate to be
opening this successful restaurant so
who do you
who's who's going to come work for you
you know i didn't have the best track
record and so for me i just i reached
out to my friends and these were the
people who showed up they believed in me
they showed up my mom started running
the wine program my best friend lauren
was by my side and ashley growing the
flowers for the restaurant they said
i'll be there i'll come wait tables i'll
come work in the kitchen and so it
started is this small group of of
friends and now it's a restaurant run by
all
women love that so much
i do
you know what else i find really helpful
is you have this
wonderful husband that you speak so
beautifully about i do and did you meet
on match.com yes the best 48 dollars i
ever spent
and like didn't you have to ask your mom
for the money
i was so so broke i was living in the
airstream on my parents property close
enough so i could have wi-fi so i could
chat with michael
and i overdrew my bank account so my mom
like came out she's like aaron you
overdrew your account so
it probably cost an extra 20 bucks for
that 48 dollars
yeah we met online and you met your
husband i winked at him just be clear
okay so he's welcome
[Laughter]
he's so lovely yes i mean the way you
speak about him is just oh it's so
romantic second chance i'm telling you
second chance i mean that's another
thing a second chance at love i didn't
know that that was possible i was just
like i came out of this terrible
marriage i had lost my sense of self and
it was like how do you go on and trust
with that and
you just got to keep putting yourself
out there and you never know and like
literally the day that i was like all
right i'm quitting match because i
overdrew my account michael and i
started chatting the next day so and now
i've got this amazing supportive loving
sweet partners
he's the one man of the lost kitchen
[Music]
you